how much longer do you have uh not too
much longer two months yeah well like
I'm 32 weeks so
and now Sarah Snook's bundle of joy has
arrived
yeah
the succession star welcomed her first
child with husband Dave Lawson pretty
proud of it shocking fans while
announcing the news during season Four's
premiere of succession do you have some
news for us tonight oh yeah uh the show
is opening come on you can't hide this
thing
congratulations thank you very much yeah
with her baby bump on full display I
heard you're keeping the gender a
surprise yes that's hard to do I did it
myself it's hard to not find out it is
it is but it's it's uh you know it's
also easy like you just sort of like
block it out you know like just uh don't
think about it too much another thing
Sarah had to block her growing belly as
she filmed the final season of her hit
series
I need to be across everything
everything yeah I mean you couldn't tell
like it's not it's not super big at the
moment still so you know there's a
there's a lot of you know beach balls
being held in front of me no umbrellas
yeah that sounds very succession while
fans mourned the HBO drama coming to an
end it left a lasting impact for many
it's such a beloved show by both you
know the people creating it as well as
the people watching it so we've been
going out on a high is also a powerful
thing it's been an amazing journey and
ride for us to go on as characters as
well as actors we've all changed you
know we've all now all had a baby per
season so I think you know the legacy of
the show will be in our kids personally
but uh in in in the in the audience's
mind I don't know I think people have
held this show up in high regard and I
hope that continues as for if any of her
on-screen siblings gave her the do's and
don'ts of parenting terrible parenting
advice
was I too harsh Jokes Aside looks like
Sarah and the little one will be part of
the Roy family for life and we will you
know we will become really close like
actual siblings yeah it feels really
real
foreign